hi I'm Nelson Coates I'm a feature film
production designer and production
designer of crazy rich Asians and here
are 10 things you probably don't know
about me run to a museum hear some music
and just try to do something totally
opposite not having the money or
resources or time to actually accomplish
what's needed to get something
accomplished people that are not
actually on board with being creative in
telling the story really big site by
fantasy or some crazy over-the-top
costume drama relax
dream big never be afraid other than
maybe a cup of coffee I don't have a
daily ritual I'm an actor and singer my
iPad it's big enough I can show a
presentation to a director and yet it's
small enough I can toss it really fast
they used to be a competition gymnast
and I like to climb mountains and do
technical climbing I always thought it
was going to be an architect a doctor or
an actor and in some ways I combined all
of that and what I do I'm basically the
set medic trying to create fixes for
health problems and stories
you